so welcome welcome everybody to this
debate we have voted and will be voting
on identity politics is tearing society
apart just to be absolutely clear these
are not indicative votes we don't have
three years to come to a conclusion and
whatever you vote we will listen and
respect the result now if at any point
this evening events change in number ten
for any reason if someone could put
their hand up that'd be very helpful for
me because I'll have to leave the table
and go back to work but on that proviso
I hope we will have a very fun evening I
am 51 years old I know I don't look it
but I am astonishingly my daughter is 19
now when I was 19
politics was left and right we worried
about nuclear war and we changed our
names to English names in the hope that
no one would notice we looked a bit
different I chose the name Neil I
thought and no criticism criticism of
any Neil's in the audience that was the
most vanilla dull name I could think of
my name of course is Kemal and I didn't
change back to Kemal until I was a
little older had a friend from the
Indian Punjab who was called Tony he
also he wasn't called Tony had a friend
from Thailand called Ian he wasn't
called Ian and I think underlined that
was a notion of what we wanted those of
us who were a bit different my father is
from Sudan my mother is from Yorkshire a
real north/south divide we wanted
acceptance now my daughter is 19 she
lives in a different world the world is
available on her supercomputer in her
hand she travels the world
she is able to say anything to many many
people anytime she wants via social
media my daughter and her friends is not
about acceptance it's about respect that
is a very very different thing and she
is concerned not so much with left or
right but with issues around identity
and the big question is is that huge
change in the type of society we are
when I wanted to share an opinion I went
down the pub and shouted at a couple of
mates about what I thought and no one
else heard it if people now want to
share an opinion they can share it with
anybody in the world and it has changed
the way we think about issues and that
notion of respect rather than acceptance
so I'm going to introduce the speakers
from my far right our first speaker for
the motion is Lionel Shriver author of
twelve novels including the bestsellers
the mandibles and the Orage Orange Prize
winner We Need to Talk About Kevin a
prolific journalist as well whose
writing has appeared in The Guardian the
New York Times The Telegraph the
spectator The Wall Street Journal and
many other publications so Lionel for
the motion please do take to the podium
and a round of applause
[Applause]
who are you most of us spend our lives
trying to evolve a nuanced sense of
ourselves but as far as the identity
politics cabal is concerned if you're an
anglo-saxon professor of economics at
UCL with a child whose drug addiction
has broken your heart a sideline as a
stand-up comic and a passion for polka
dancing all you are is white worse
privileged meaning you should be ashamed
of yourself and none of your
achievements are to your credit for the
term identity politics implies a
worldview the dogma couches human
history exclusively in terms of unequal
power relationships between groups thus
all of life reduces to human hierarchy
an individual's identity derived solely
from membership of a collective in the
service of a revolutionary social
justice your rights will right to be
heard to avail yourself of social
resources and to defend your own
interests depend entirely on your having
been marginalized due to race race
ethnicity sexual preference gender or
disability hilariously the bulk of
identity politics Crusaders are actually
well-off white people competing over who
can be more righteous I grew up during
the civil rights and women's liberation
movements in the United States I was a
fierce advocate of both but the goal of
these earlier campaigns was to break
down the artificial barriers between us
and to release us all into seeing each
other not as black or white or male or
female but as individual people granted
with race and sex we've still got a ways
to go but one of the greatest
impediments to fully breaking free of
our pigeonholes is the rise of identity
politics for we all fall into categories
that weren't of our choosing I was born
white female and American no one asked
me beforehand whether I wanted to tick
those boxes and they are boxes so I've
never wanted these categories to define
me as I wouldn't want the categories
into which the folks in this audience
were unwillingly born to define you
either the color of my skin is an
arbitrary accident not a personal brand
as a woman I often break the mold I'm
outspoken and sometimes unpleasantly
aggressive I dress badly I even make a
pretty lousy American having spent most
of my adult life in the UK for me the
boxes into which I was born had been
confinements I've struggled to get out
of and I would wish that liberation for
everyone else identity politics urges us
all instead to cling to the bars of our
cages in locating advantage in
disadvantage to the movement pushes
historically marginalized groups to
deploy weakness as a weapon thus you're
strongly motivated to maintain that
weakness the better to push other people
around with the unfairness of your
terrible plight perversely then victims
of racism sexism or homophobia say
logically grow attack attached to the
very prejudiced from which they suffer
because prejudice translates into power
and without victimhood they have no idea
who they are
ironically the last thing the arctan
identity politics crowd wants to see is
a truly equitable society absent bigotry
it's activists would be lost identity
politics doesn't eliminate human
hierarchy but simply flips the totem
pole upside down thus at the very bottom
sit awful undeserving ly advantaged
white people and at the very very bottom
white straight males who according to
this Creed have no rights and no biz
is venturing an opinion about anything
who are obliged to check their privilege
aka
shut the [ __ ] up well I reject out of
hand that any group should be told they
have no rights and they have to put a
sock in it I happen to be married to a
white straight male and I'm often very
interested in what he has to say
according to identity politics the sins
of the father are visited visited upon
the sons if you're white you accept
responsibility for slavery colonialism
and the slaughter of native peoples from
Australia to America but do we really
believe in infinitely inherited guilt
let's all be historically clear-eyed but
Germans coming of age today oughtn't to
feel personally responsible for Dachau
nor should any of us pretend to feel
guilty about something we know perfectly
well we didn't do have you noticed how
many headlines these days involve race
how as sociologist Documenta steady
decline in racial prejudice relations
between races seem to be getting worse
that's because this movement is
inherently adversarial it thrives on
enemies though ostensibly concerned with
victimhood its proponents gleefully seek
victims of their own identity Rian's
have created a cutthroat predatory
environment in which often anonymous
self-appointed culture police prowl the
halls of the internet searching for
perceived violations of their
orthodoxies using the wrong word
reaching for the wrong pronoun allowing
that amidst all the plunder and
domination maybe countries colonized by
Britain enjoyed one or two teeny-tiny
benefits can now get you set for this
movement has issued and not the color
and gender blindness we aspire to in my
youth but a hyper awareness of race
gender and ethnicity
implicitly the ideology pits
disadvantaged groups against one another
in a competition over who's been treated
more badly rather than calling us to a
shared community it fosters a climate of
anxiety division antagonism touchiness
and paranoia
so in our universities faculties are
terrified to teach or publish anything
that might conceivably step on a
minorities toes self-censorship is rife
persecution common in workplaces
employees negotiate a minefield of
microaggressions and are afraid to make
jokes in my occupation fiction is vetted
by sensitivity readers while many of my
fellow writers are frightened of
crafting characters different from
themselves lest they break a host of
proliferating unwritten rules in social
settings many of us have if anything
grown less likely to approach a stranger
of a different race and not because
we're bigots but because we're fearful
that we might inadvertently say the
wrong thing I don't call that progress
inexorably to identity politics has
conjured the boogeyman of white identity
politics now on the rise in the US if
we're all to understand each other in
terms of our helpless membership of
groups white people are going to
understand themselves in those terms as
well and it's interesting how
unattractive it is to brandish your skin
color as the most important aspect of
your sense of self when white people
start doing it - certainly many of the
folks staging this festival of taking
offense are well intended we should all
be alert to the fact that others may
have experienced social and professional
travails that we haven't yet surely the
power dynamics of human hierarchies
can't explain everything looking out the
window and seeing only degrees of
victimhood
is a flat oppressive reductive and
depressing way of looking at the world
sometimes it's a relief to think about
something else
architecture color and light outer space
so I for one do not plan on embracing my
skin color or my gender or sexual
preference as the cynic WA known of my
character for I reject outright the very
concept of identity that this poisonous
overtly racist and sexist outlook
promotes I like dancing to Talking Heads
I'm a big fan of Graham green Richard
Yates and Edith Wharton I've published
13 books of my own and whatever their
failings those novels are a part of who
I am I love the word mellifluous I over
used the word insidious I have a
weakness for Poldark I'm a mediocre
tennis player who makes up for her
deficits on the court with Shira Byul
Ian's that and more is my identity so if
anyone aims to put Lionel Shriver
straight white female on my tombstone
I'm definitely getting cremated
thank you very much thank you very much
Lionel not to not to insidious there
our first speaker against the motion
identity politics is tearing society
apart is born foster dawn please take to
the podium Guardian columnist who writes
on politics Social Affairs and economics
and also a staff writer for Jacobin
magazine dawn
[Applause]
so as some of you might have noticed I'm
a woman I'm white I have a disability
and when I think about politics when I
talk about politics a lot of those
identities come into it
so when I think about austerity I look
at how austerity affects certain groups
more than others so in particular
austerity affects women 82% of all cuts
that the government have made our impact
women if you look at the if you look at
the pay gap for instance women are paid
less than men but if you narrow it down
black women are paid a lot less than
than other than other people so when you
think about politics identity does have
to come into it because everybody
experiences things differently you know
personally but also in terms of
economics in terms of you know how it
affects the community etc I'm going to
think about the people well when I come
across the people who complain about
this it always seems to be exclusively
boomers sorry
I am closer in age to Kyle's daughter
than Kemal so I am I am of the
generation that is part yet partly
interested in identity politics I don't
think it I don't think it deflates
things I think you know people live
their life in a normal way and obviously
your identity is part of that so
everything that affects you everything
that makes see it makes up it makes up
the person that is you including your
likes your hobbies or dislikes etc it
all comes together to form a whole
person and I don't think that you know
talking to people and understanding that
people have different views different
experiences of life you know because of
different identities I don't think it
actually like deflates things I don't
think it puts people in a box I think it
allows us be more expansive with policy
I think he allows us to look at
political policy and think about how
different groups will be affected by it
and that you know and therefore stop
discrimination within that kind of thing
there's a lot there is a huge amount of
concern about universities about people
being no platformed about people not
being allowed to speak it cetera and I
always find it really fascinating that
so many people get upset by a small
number of students in the Student Union
when almost nobody else will have heard
of these little these small societies
these small groups and I think it's I
think the big problem is that we have
older people who have you know columns
in big magazines huge access of media
constantly saying that they are being
silenced I know this because they write
constantly that they are being silenced
they go on TV to talk about the fact
that they have been silenced and you
know I think if they were I wouldn't be
constantly hearing about them and I
think you know I think actually I don't
see politics helps those people because
it allows them to constantly place
articles in the spectator in spiked
magazine in all sorts of places talking
about the fact that they have been
silenced and that identity politics is
ruining their life etc and you know
think about Lionel speech I have a lot
of friends who are white men and I don't
look at them and say good lord you're so
privileged it's disgusting because they
are my friends and I don't think of
people you know in small I don't put
people in small boxes I don't look at
them as a you know having a tick box on
their chest that explains things about
them I think that you know for instance
me haven't haven't disability changes my
life than what I'm in hospital a lot my
friends know that and come and see me
but it doesn't really change anything
else I might need some things like for
instance if we decide to have strobe
light in here
I wouldn't be able to sit and sage but
that's about it
don't do that
and I find it really really fascinating
that the big panic comes from older
people a very small number of older
people who you know who as you know
Lionel was saying that the people who
are into integrated politics are
relatively wealthy tend to be white etc
but whenever I read articles about
people being silent so that people being
kicked out by the empty politics it's
always homeowners in their 50s it's
always people who are relatively
comfortable haven't lived through the
you know the global financial crash
didn't really affect them it seems you
know it seemed such an obsession with
with those people I've met people who
were absolutely desperate to get removed
from panels just because they wanted to
talk about the backlash that came with
it
and they knew that if they were removed
from a small panel in Student Union they
could make a huge amount of money
talking about it you know going on the
BBC talking about how they were silenced
writing as a spectator about how they
were silenced and absolutely nobody at
any point thinking why because they
aren't clearly this person's being
punished everybody I think that empty
politics is actually really really
helpful in terms of making sure that we
think more deeply about how policy
affects people about how we can stop
kind of get you know gaps in admission
so University how we can stop people
being paid less how we can look at the
fact that if you are disabled you are
less likely to get a job and how we can
you know change things to bring other
people in and I think that I think that
we have to move past the you know
terrifying fear that a lot of boomers
have around this you know people when I
look at my friends I don't you know that
have tick box in my head that appears
like you know like some kind of sci-fi
thing that breaks down what they are and
who they are we might have conversations
about
kind of you know what so I'm stationed
with my friend the other day about the
fact that they had been the victim of a
homophobic attack but I don't he doesn't
always come up and sometimes it does and
it's very I think it's a lot more useful
to talk about it and think about how
discrimination happens and how we can
stop that from happening one one really
really key bit I think David will talk
about this is university admissions so
for instance Oxford you know had a huge
race problem they have a huge class
problem and you know bringing that up
and talking about it means that they
will actually take some some action and
think about that there have been some
court cases where people have looked at
the fact that you know certain policies
are bound to affect women therefore they
are discriminatory other policies for
instance like exclusively seems to hit
disabled people and those people have
gone to court and talked about the fact
they've been discriminated against and
often one of the cases and change the
policy so I think that you know if we
want to have a more equal society there
is no way we can do that without
thinking about identity without thinking
about how certain things mean that other
people find it harder to get into
certain jobs find it harder to reach
certain things or even you know come
into a building because there isn't a
wheelchair ramp so I think that you know
identity politics is not about deciding
who who is a villain who is the most
privileged who we should you know never
ever talk about and attack and we talk
about their privilege I think it's much
more about making sure that our society
is more welcoming to people and that
political policy doesn't discriminate
against individuals and big groups
it doesn't Roman austerity massively
affects women and it massively you know
if you are a woman and you are disabled
you're doubly discriminated against by
certain policies that is identity
politics and you know I think we need to
remember that if we are making policy it
needs to be more
well it needs to make sure that for
instance if you are a young black person
and you're applying for a certain job
you know or a placement University you
aren't discriminated against by the way
that the interview takes place and so I
think identity politics is about
equality it's about making sure that
everybody has the same access and that
access might be slightly different based
on their identity and I think that it's
led to a lot of people thinking more
deeply about how they act and how
society should be built so I you know
I'm against emotion I think that we
should be more equal and I think the
identity politics is key to that we
can't move past identity we can't ignore
identity and I think that you know maybe
at some point the boomers will
understand that
thank you very much dawn thank you very
much
our next speaker for the motion trevor
phillips to my right was chair of the
equality and human rights commission
between 2003 and 2012 the co-founder of
the diversity analytics consultancy
Weber Phillips and he is presently
chairman of the index on Censorship he's
a director of the Barbican Art Center
and vice-president of the Royal
Television Society
well good evening and thank you for
inviting me to be part of this
discussion I didn't really to be
actually honest with you I don't really
know what intelligent squared was before
has asked to be part of this it's a
tribute to their organization that this
number of people can turn out on a
lovely evening where you could be doing
something much better to listen to us
thank you so much thank you so much
so let me introduce myself I'm the tenth
of ten children of an immigrant family
came here in 1950 with descendants of
slaves including a woman the earliest
known member of our family
she was called happy presumably some
slave owners idea of a great joke
further back we would have come from the
Mandinka or Fulani people of West Africa
like David he also comes from Guyana
that's a whole other identity story to
tell you but we're great my ancestors
were there for Muslims but of course we
had all that whipped out of us probably
in our case by the biggest plantation
owners in British Guiana John Gladstone
yes the father of the liberal Prime
Minister William Glen's
Gladstone and the largest single
beneficiary of compensation after
abolition I also have a professional
identity I used to do TV don't do much
these days I've only made three films in
the last 20 years before that with my
brother Mike I wrote the book and made
the series which told the Windrush story
first today I Acadian write for
newspapers and magazines but mostly I'm
basically a boring businessman I chair a
talent business called Green Park and
for the past four years I was president
of accounts of the John Lewis
Partnership I run a small data analytics
business is probably a legacy of my time
as a chemist when I was young I said all
that out tricks tried to explain why I
come at this debate from the way I do my
background may explain some of what I
say I agree with some of what dawn said
by the way identity is more important
because it now represents some real
interests that for the first time in
many century
has a voice women obviously minorities
when my father came here the white
family who lived across the road could
afford to be friendly with us they knew
that no matter how clever
my dad was how hard he worked how
ambitious he might be when it came to
getting a job or a house or a loan we
would never be ahead of them in the
queue that divided us from them not
income not the area we lived but that
thing that thing and by the way it's not
just poor people of color who suffer
because we have an argument no doubt
about class here when I was chairman of
the Commission for racial equality the
people who were most affected who wept
in my office were not young black men
Harris by the police they were the
teacher who knew that because he was
black or Asian he would never become a
department head the lawyer who knew that
no matter how clever she was and how
hard she worked she was never going to
take silk and the doctors who knew that
they would always be junior doctors and
never consultants they had done
everything that this society asked of
them everything but the prison of their
skin kept them in the place that meant
they would never never reap the rewards
of their diligence so I understand all
of that and if that's all that the
identity politics were about would it be
short debate we could also be agree
there are some other things that it
shouldn't it it's not about I was the US
president who wrote and moved and
persuaded the NUS conference in 1973 to
adopt the no platform policy we wanted
to keep the fascist off campus nobody
today thinks that Germaine Greer or
Julie bindle should be in that category
we can agree about that
nobody today thinks that white men
should continue staging the city than
they do in the boardrooms of our great
companies except then we don't have to
have an argument about that and nobody
believes that it's okay to abuse public
figures I got my first bag full of hate
mail when I became the NUS president in
1978 I was 24 years old and I had a
whole bag full of it including a
charming cartoon which drew my own
lynching nobody will argue that that
should be part of our politics so I
don't think we need to devote a lot of
time to all of that nor should we spend
a lot of time comforting ourselves with
the thought that we are virtuous and
folks out there who want the fact that
none of us is nigel farage doesn't let
us off the hook on this issue clever and
nice people can be racist - Albert
Einstein called the Chinese and
industrious filthy obtuse people one of
my friends and somebody I admire in
politics once called on the government
he led to ensure British job for British
workers we made tonight talk about
institutional racism or sexism Stokely
Carmichael came up with that phrase for
a very specific reason it was a critique
of Martin Luther King Carmichael said
that point where he was making was that
racism was so baked into society that
you could have a police force full of
black angels and they might still be
shooting black people everybody said
that don't be ridiculous
50 years on the killings of young black
men all over the USA often by black
police officers says the Carmichael was
right so tonight this is really for me
about politics in its place in society
there's only one reason for politics to
exist and that is to help us solve
problems now for over a century and a
half our political architectures
followed economic and social divisions
workers to the left bosses to the right
but we're in an era of extreme possibly
unprecedent
disruption and the real tribal divide in
our society symbolizes the deepest
differences about what kind of people
want to be I'm a remainer
Pro globalization massively plural
immigration Pro technology socially
liberal London centric you expect that
but I don't disrespect my many relatives
who live in say Essex or Nottingham who
feel just as passionately
anti-globalization cautious about
immigration and that includes my black
relatives anti digitization and who
loathe London's arrogance a survey taken
after the referendum asked about
people's attitude to various topics on
the economy on capitalism there was
absolutely no difference between remain
errs and leavers fifty-one percent
thought capitalism was a force for ill
49 percent force for good asked about
multiculturalism 71 percent of remain us
thought it was a force for good 81
percent of levers thought it was a force
for ill 60 percent of remainders were
Pro feminism lower than I expect 74
percent of levers were against feminism
my point is it is these issues of
identity that are dividing us this
debate is really about one thing
identity politics is a politics that is
tearing our society apart I think that
objectively true but perhaps where I
differ with the other panelists possibly
including Lionel is that they will all
lament this fact I don't I think it is a
wonderful thing
our opponents confront the world with
timidity in the hope that the existing
political architecture can be tweaked
and twisted into coping Poli Toynbee
versus Richard Littlejohn labor versus
Tory none of that work for me or for 60%
of the British people who say there is
nobody I can vote for if you really
believe in liberation this is going to
be struggle what makes you think that
the straight white propertied men are
going to give it up without a fight our
society will be torn apart in
to get justice we need a political map
now that allows us to represent the true
divisions in our society one my daughter
said to me when I told the wall is going
to say tonight oh I see you're
channeling samuel l.jackson what the
hell do you mean what she said Sam would
just get up and he'd say this
everything's changing politics has got
to change too let's just tear this
[ __ ] down and start something
new
thank you very much Trevor fortunately
this isn't being broadcast live on the
BBC there's quite a lot of bad language
I feel or around us which is to be
warned against before I call our next
speaker up just to say that I have the
results in front of me of your initial
votes which I will be announcing after
our fourth speaker has finished and then
once David Lammy has finished we'll be
coming to the floor for your chance to
question these brainy folk up here
before voting again so but before all
that we'll go to our final speaker
against the motion identity politics is
tearing society apart David Lammy Labour
MP for Tottenham one of Parliament's
most prominent campaigners for social
justice famously led the recent campaign
for the Windrush generation to be
granted British citizenship he's fought
for justice for the gren fault our
families and of course has run the
high-profile campaign calling on
Oxbridge to improve access for students
from underrepresented and disadvantaged
backgrounds David the floor is yours
right so I'm listening to the speakers
and I'm thinking about a young David
Lammy growing up in Tottenham in the
1970s it's the young David Lammy that
looks like Michael Jackson and wants to
be Michael Jackson and that young David
Lammy would never have believed that the
tide of human progress would bring me
here in front of you able to articulate
to speak to have the confidence to do
that I was also thinking of another
young but a bit older David Lammy who
walked into the House of Commons at the
beginning of that Tony Blair government
by that point I look more like Denzel
Washington this was a period of
consensus politics Clinton Blair knew
labour things were coming together we
had 10 consecutive quarters of growth
and a kind of cool Britannia emerged
where you know there were a lot of drugs
as well things but you know dance music
but people loved one another Here I am
2019 I now look like Forrest Whitaker
tomorrow people will be voting in the
European elections and many will vote
for what I see as hard right parties and
positions this is an age of Trump of
Faraj of Jacob Riis MOG of Boris Johnson
and we are accusing identity politics of
tearing society apart the great story of
the 20th century was probably democracy
but if there is a second story theme
that arcs that century surely it is
rights and that by the end of that
century so many human beings who started
off at the beginning of the 20th century
subjugated oppressed could actually
begin to self-actualize in their own
lifetimes women got the vote and with
the invention of the pill control over
their own bodies ethnic minorities
colonized remember those pink bits of
the atlas over so much of the world
broke off because of the powerful words
and behavior of people like Gandhi from
that colonization workers came from
being exploited burst movements like the
Labour Party and I still believe at its
best the best progressive cause in our
country and now same-sex marriage and
those who are LGBT taking their place
when it's only in 1967 that you could be
imprisoned because of the person that
you love that is a remarkable story
the story that is the story of the 20th
century and of course that is a story
about identity because when Martin
Luther King spoke and he talked about
judging somebody by the character of
their soul not by the color of their
skin have we arrived at that and even
though that was a goal even though that
was a goal he didn't Park his identity
at the door to get that goal and neither
did Harvey Milk fighting for gay rights
in San Francisco and Beyond and all
those fighting for Disability Rights so
for me identity politics is about
empathy it is about dignity and my god
I look Nigel Farage in the face and I
say it's about compassion compassion for
your fellow human being so we stand by
that progress despite all that we have
to do we're now in a period where those
on the right dismiss it when I raised
concerns about who should leave the
inquiry into those poor people that died
desperately included a friend of mine on
the 20th floor of Grenville Tower burned
to death a young woman called Khadija se
and I raised questions about who should
lead that inquiry because actually in
the role that I play in public life
someone should say does it have to be
another white male privileged upper
class judge not because he can't do a
good job joe Scarman did a good job when
he led the riots into the Brixton riots
but is there not in Britain in 2019 an
ethnic minority law
or even a woman that could take that
role and I say that at a point in our
country where only 7% of the judges are
from an ethnic minority background and
we have one one woman on our Supreme
Court progress so much more so much more
to do and those on the left of course
class and economic equality inequality
have to be challenged that's the basis
of my politics but those who fight for
rights today do not stand opposed to
issues of inequality that exists in our
society just as there were LGBT people
who set up solidarity funds to fight for
the miners you can be alongside those in
that battle for against inequality in
our society and yes there are moments
when it goes too far if you're tweeting
or writing white people are trash kill
all men that is identity politics that I
would not want to associate myself with
but let us be clear on the proposition
let us really single in on what may be
tearing our society apart populism might
well be tearing our society apart
populism on the hard right and populism
on the hard left austerity cuts brutal
cuts to local authorities right up and
down the country the biggest north-south
divides since 1911 that may be tearing
our society apart grim poverty chronic
housing conditions right across this
city that means so many people who
could be in this audience aren't in this
audience that could be tearing our
society apart gross inequality with 44%
of the UK's wealth owned by just 10% of
our population 50% of the land in the UK
owned by 1% of the population that could
be the proposition that could be tearing
our society apart but instead this
proposition asks you blame the
Bangladeshi woman blame the trans man
blame the individual with disability and
then they say they're victims and we
heard that language from Lionel
victimhood the victimhood that is being
manipulated in our country is a
victimhood that's being peddled today by
Nigel Farage it is not the Vixen hood of
the people I just described so reject
this proposition it is not tearing our
society apart
it's an arc that begins with people like
Mandela Martin Luther King Gandhi Emily
pang curse stand alongside it because in
the age that we are in there is a big
difference between dignity compassion
and human rights and the populism that
would rip our country asunder
thank you very much David
thank you very much David so we're gonna
um I think possibly up there reveal the
initial vote for and against the motion
and if it doesn't pop up I will read it
out I will read it out as Hannah tells
me to do as I do what Hannah tells me
because that's an important part of this
organization so for the motion identity
politics is tearing society apart 50%
agree
against the motion identity politics is
tearing society apart thirteen percent
undecided those of you who tall this
note sorry didn't tear this and just put
it in on its own thirty seven percent so
the panel you have got a large undecided
group and you may actually move some
people between those two numbers but
before we go to questions clearly those
for the motion are in the not the
majority but in the lead
not quite the majority so let's have
questions from the floor hands up and I
will take batches of three and I will
distribute them amongst the panel as I
see fit as I am the chair number four
hello um so I think the panel of doing
an ad and up hello see you thank you
very much I think the panel have done a
really admirable job of resisting sort
of ascribing identity politics to a
particular area on the political
spectrum there's an emerging
understanding however I think that this
is a phenomenon that really belongs more
favorably on the political left and for
liberalism I'm quite interested in the
emerging idea that almost inadvertently
identity politics is inhibiting genuine
social change because by encouraging
people to embrace micro facets of
individual identity we are inhibiting
the possibility of the type of
collective group action that's really
needed to affect meaningful change on a
broad actually important social level
and therefore may be inadvertently
maintained in the status quo and
actually being more favorable to quite
extreme right-wing views I just like to
get some of the panel's thoughts on that
okay thank you very much number two
our minds are quite quick one and you
spoke a lot about Nigel Farage at the
under is he not a big purveyor of
identity politics I thought I'd just you
know for mock me breaks it party you
cute this is peak identity politics now
it's about identity thank you very much
and number three is identity politics
tied to socialism is it a form of
socialism in the sense that rather than
economic equal economic outcomes rather
we're looking for equal outcomes between
different genders classes or not class
but race gender etc okay fabulous thank
you very much so if I could kick off
first maybe dawn with you on the
question from the back left there
identity identity politics in and of
itself is actually harming change and is
stopping us having the type of
conversations we could have so oddly
small C is a conservative movement I
completely agree with the
characterization of what you said about
a lot of the talk about identity
politics online I think that basically a
small number of people very very small
facet on the on the internet who are
relatively extreme in how they define
identity politics how they talk about it
have been publicized massively and
characterized as as a huge movement and
often people talk about this for a
relatively small group online as it as
it as if they you know represent
everybody I think they're a very very
small extreme facet that get a lot of
attention online but the majority of
people who think about identity politics
who think about how agency affects
things in everyday life aren't part of
that group they don't spend a lot of
time online talking about it they spend
a lot more time volunteering they spend
a lot more time looking at problems in
society and I think that
I've never been involved in a in a
volunteering group or talking about what
policy should look like etc with Sintang
cetera
I've never kind of come up against any
barriers because people have talked
about identity politics that stop us
from getting further so I think that a
very small group online characterized as
you know the entirety of under of
identity politics when for the majority
people aren't involved in that
relatively small group in liberalism and
I think it is liberalism rather than
socialism in this case and they are
characterized as the entire group
because they are very extreme and they
fulfill a lot of the kind of worries
about these things on the right but in
everyday life I don't see that instead I
see people thinking more about when they
when they talk about policies there
should be you know in government they
look more deeply at how they affect
different groups and I don't see that
that group online has any way lyonell
the questions seem to be pointing
towards the notion that identity
politics allows for a form of micro
extremism which stops us talking about
things and it's quite conservative but
Dawn's point is that that's a
mischaracterization that actually your
characterization of shutting down
debates violate thanks to politics isn't
the case it's not true when you actually
talk to people about their identities
you're confusing the aggression of
Twitter with identity politics I see
that aggression everywhere including on
Twitter and other social media platforms
but I and I certainly see it in the
extremists on college campuses and
that's not necessarily on social media I
don't think you can conveniently exclude
the less attractive and more shrill
proponents of this ideology because they
don't help your case
um do you talk about this particular
that particular question okay well I
don't think this is actually just about
extremes one of the things that is
happening on college campuses and I see
somebody who is sitting in this audience
who is actually or is currently an
object of this is that you don't have to
have a sort of big whoo Ferrari Ferrari
about people being their platforms and
so on for something quite dramatic to
happen one of the things that is taking
place right now is that the boundaries
that describe for example what will
bring your employ into disrepute up are
shifting and one of the things that
we're seeing on college campuses is that
the disciplinary procedure procedure is
being used because it is said somebody
who has for example made a disciplining
remark about about women or indeed about
trans people is there for bringing the
college or the university in to
distribute and at least two people by
now have been fired for this point now
the question is do you have that
argument or do you simply put people
outside of the door and what we are
doing right now and this is what I think
people are talking about when they talk
about that identity politics not exactly
what I mean but what they mean is that
actually a shutting down debate what is
actually happening is it is becoming
more and more difficult more and more
uncertain what you can say without
facing that kind of treatment and I
think that is where this is really
getting traction and it will leak off
the campus into other places into
employees the question is how do we deal
with this okay
if the person if the person hold Ondo if
the person may have been wants a
platform here please
put their hand up David answer that
point that Trevor just made but also
answer the point that doesn't your
constant or the question doesn't your
constant reference to Nigel Faraj reveal
that identity politics is tearing
society apart because his the questioner
was suggesting is a type of identity
politics Nigel Farage is playing out of
a playbook that is far longer than the
identity politics prefix it's a playbook
that you can look back to in the 1920s
it's what happens after economic
downturn its blame the immigrant blamed
the other it's their fault that your
situation is what is so so I'm not sure
it's completely right to ascribe to here
yes he's yes of course he is he is
playing to an audience and it is an
audience that but it's not entirely you
know there's a lot said about white
working-class there are many many people
in the Home Counties there they own
homes they have nice pensions they're
still attracted to that rhetoric so it's
much more confident the reason why I was
a little bit down on what Trevor said is
only a little bit is that one confining
this conversation to what's happening on
University campuses is incredibly
limited because university campuses in
the end effect largely middle-class kids
who are going to go on to be part of a
liberal elite and they've always been
roused on University campuses of across
much of the developed world the second
thing is ok so
lionel's some lecturers have got a bit
be careful about what they say hang on a
minute my ancestors have to be really
careful about what they said women had
to be really careful about what they say
okay gay men and women you know they're
still living in jobs not able to be who
they are
let's get real about where the real pain
is
I'm so sorry that you well-paid
university professor and writer she had
a little bit carefully about your
language despite your amazing Ivy League
education I think you can work it out I
think you can work it out thank you
thank you Dave just on this point I
wasn't sure whether this was seen as a
pro or a con or maybe neither is
identity politics basically socialism by
another name
like I think one of the odd things about
this ideology is that it is less attuned
to class than usual than the usual
arguments about equality and it's much
more focused on these qualities that as
I discussed in my talk that we have no
choice about that that it's it's about
identities we were born into and and
there there is a demonization of white
privilege but one of the problems with
the key thinking of people in these
boxes is that the people inside those
boxes are actually in very different
economic circumstances so one of the
weird consequences of the use of
affirmative action quotas in university
admissions in the United States is that
a lot of people who are being advantaged
by it are in fact incredibly well-off
Africans you know the consensus those
are pretty much the Africans that make
it all the way to the United States
people with money and it's and therefore
these boxes don't really work on a
socialist level because they're full of
all different classes and all different
levels of of advantage and it's one of
the reasons one of the reasons of many
that the boxes don't work do you agree
with your your your coke
and your supporter on this fight against
diverting publicity Spacey's also
possible African people have come across
and they're the ones who are shouting
about it at that my father is from Sudan
he was quite poor she's now dead sadly
I'm sure I'm just getting my head around
the ocean dead amber look I thought I
agree with what lino said but can I just
make it two very quick point about
what's been said on this question it's
not just universities I happen not to
agree with the individual who did this I
mean I think it's it probably is
unprofessional but a nurse has got fired
for praying in front of a patient now
personally if I were her employer I
would say that that's conduct that we're
not really keen on because there are
some kind of things that you don't want
to have in the workplace but to get
hired or pray I mean it has happened
she's appealed it's gone now this is
where we're going with all of this and
if I may come back to the point about
that we've raised about about forests oh
by the way I just almost socialism it
speaking from the speeches tonight as
the most left-wing person on this panel
I don't recognize the voice from
socialism you're talking about it's got
nothing to do with it under the fair
eyes thing I don't want to get into an
argument about fairer eyes himself
because we've had lots of that but one
of the things that one of the things
that we should observe about Donald
Trump I spend a lot of my time in the
United States now one thing we should
observe about Donald Trump is the manner
in which he has completely refashioned
the Republican Party it has become a
white nationalist party it has
absolutely a solid base and that is
because Trump I know what everybody
hates him and all that but the most
modern politician has realized what
politics is doing and he has created an
instrument that fits
to the political cleavages that really
exist in the United States right now
that is if you want the best evidence on
that side of the Atlantic for the fact
that we need to rethink what we do the
old 'aqaq architecture can't work we
can't beat the populist we can't beat
the populist with the 19th and 20th
century architecture of politics okay
thank you Joe let's have some more
questions fairly where the numbers
popping up for me to see I can see lots
of hands but no numbers with people with
mics number two sorry I can see one so
the lights are very bright
number two yep and then number four
hello you said that populism may be
tearing our society apart and you said
identity politics isn't the thing to
blame well there are many cases where
identity politics is used for populism
for example in Turkey where I come from
Edwin is using religion a type of
identity and he's using it as populism
and he's getting people who have the
same identity to support him so surely
identity politics and populism are
related
Thank You number four
[Music]
number four stand up thank you hello oh
yeah thank you and yeah my question is
to those who are against the motion
because I need a bit more clarity on
what their arguments are because they
seem to talk about austerity and Viraj
and stuff like that and I don't think
that's really the topic that we're
discussing dawn said the austerity
affects 82% more women than men that may
be true I don't know but you know if you
wanted to raise the tax rate on higher
earners that would probably affect more
men than women I don't understand by
looking at the demographics the policies
affect why that should play a role in
deciding whether we think it's good
policy or not I'm not sure why it
affects them more women or men is a
reason for me to oppose austerity I
oppose austerity because it harms people
men and women I don't understand why it
harming women you know do we say that
things that harm women matter more than
things that harm men that seems to just
be pitting men and women against each
other okay thank you very much number
three identity politics has been linked
quite frequently in this debate to
equality so my question is do you think
if equality of opportunity has been
achieved or will be achieved can that or
would that then result in equality of
outcome okay okay
dawn for the gentleman at the back could
you explain why you linked the notion of
identity politics to the differential
effects of policies which you've
discussed and answer the question that
just because something tends towards as
you argue tends to affect negatively
certain groups that that isn't actually
identity politics at each and things
that have affect women negatively if
they also affect men there shouldn't be
a dividing line there yeah I mean I
brought that up because I think that if
you have a policy that like massively
affects a certain group and stops them
from achieving certain thing
in life then you have a you have a bad
policy
I mean austerity is bad for a number of
reasons not least the fact that it's
been shown economically not to work but
if you have a policy that like
deliberate that very deliberately it
stops a quality of opportunity for
certain people then there's no reason to
have that policy if you had upon the see
that like massively affected disabled
people you would again saying this is a
very policy and I think that if you
looked at you know raising tax on higher
earners and it affected more more men
than women that's because men tend to
earn a lot more it's not because you
know the government hate men and move
that way it seems to be the point was
that if a policy affects a certain group
of people but also face another group of
people but fewer of them it doesn't make
it less important for the group that
happened to be in the minority in terms
of the effects no I think that again you
can have a policy that is racist because
it always exclusively affects black
people you could have a policy that is
sexist because it almost exclusively
affects women and you know we used to
have we have quality audits on policies
and people and people would look at what
would happen to to people beforehand
we've scrapped that and that means often
we do have policies that are
discriminatory that was something that
the equality Human Rights Commission you
see quite understand the point well a
quality audits before policies were put
in place yeah they're still there on me
that well oh they're not no they're not
your your your there's guidance that you
can do it but it's not what we what we
wanted compulsory right okay David what
about the point that the questioner over
there raised identity politics is
tearing society apart as he explains
anyone in Turkey would tell you
I have a large Kurdish population in my
constituency I think it's the biggest in
the country and many Kurds are on the
rough end of treatment from erga 1 in
terms of their language their liberties
nevermind the judges the journalists and
the conspiracy of silence frankly from
the West in relation to what he is doing
in Turkey my own sense of what's
happening in Turkey is far deeper than
the description described as identity
politics but you are right of course
there are people using identity as a
means to push a kind of totalitarianism
in relation to their populations of
course that is happening or to
preference one group and of course I'm
you know I I think we always have to
challenge supremacy and I don't just
talk about white supremacy when I say
that I'm talking about people in the
world who effectively our ethnic
nationalists saying that one group of
people are more supreme than others and
that is what he is up to in Turkey but I
say also in this country and that's why
I talk about Faraj to go to the question
at the back that there are people who
want to describe particularly English
identity I I'm really comfortable being
British but I want to assert very
strongly I am also English and I want to
challenge those who want to confine
Englishness to solely an ethnic
anglo-saxon identity I defend my right
to be English and so yes there are
people doing that yes there are people
doing that but because they are doing
that is not the reason to then challenge
those who are clearly still far behind
in the pecking order as I said the
Bangladeshi woman the trans
deny them their rights in order to say
we are all the same and that is what you
hear and Lionel that's what I picked up
in part of somehow somehow our common
humanity means we cannot talk about
identity because in the end that is
usually used by those in a privileged
position to shut down it's like those
who say to me please don't talk about
judges David and hooba gets to be a
judge you've got to be a judge on merit
why is merit always defined as an
Oxbridge educated public school educated
white male or is merit found in other
areas it shuts down possibilities and
that is why I believe identity politics
yes it's real but it's it's it's it's
necessary it's not about being good it's
necessary and those who those who defend
and want to extend rights to have equal
rights
it's not about claiming you're better
than of it's simply about reclaiming
your human dignity and that human
dignity that fight for human dignity
goes on can I just I've got a touch on
this socialism point just a touch the
associates by the there are some and let
me today they exist in my party they
might be on the far left of politics and
they believe that chaos somehow the
brexit party winning in the European
elections the Tories in disarray is good
for labour because it lets us in my
problem with those hard left activists
some of whom I think work in the leaders
office is they would throw ethnic
minorities under the bus
whilst we get that revolution that's my
problem
with those that want to focus solely on
the class war and screw ethnic
minorities LGBTQ and others who when the
fascists come will be the first in the
queue Lionel
just answer the question around equality
of opportunity and equality of outcome
if there were equality of opportunity
would there be equality of outcome I
think was what the lady was asking
gradually it's all I can answer equality
I'm the end model these prejudices
wouldn't would it would not be
instantaneous and I think one of the
reasons that we have a an insistence
increasingly on equality of outcome is
is social impatience and I am
sympathetic with that impatience I would
love to be able to press a button and
make make a perfectly level playing
field for everyone regardless of the
circumstances in which they were born
but social change
I'm afraid doesn't work that way and
when you try to instantaneously achieve
the kind of equal society you envision
you end up creating yet more unfairness
instead of getting the the fair world
that you want you want to take a example
the New York Times a few months ago
announced that it was dismayed that it
was publishing more men's letters to the
editors than women and and they really
wanted to equalize it but they conceded
to the readership that two-thirds at
least if not 3/4 of the letters they get
are from men so they now have a new goal
that in less than a year from now they
planned on to have a in a letters page
that will be 50/50 now in my view that's
too fast that's the kind of pushing the
button that I'm talking about because
what's really going to happen it means
that if you're male and you write into
the New York Times that
chances of your getting n regardless of
the quality of your argument or the
fineness of your prose goes way down in
order to advantage the few women who
write in and of course in the perfect
world I'd see a roughly 5050 letters
page maybe but what I really care about
as a reader of that newspaper is that
they're good letters and they don't
really care whether they're written by
men or women okay long Anna and
therefore that's what you get that's
when you sacrifice when you you insist
on equality of outcome regardless of
equality of input you get more injustice
okay thank you long Trevor it's very
briefly equality of opportunity will it
ultimately lead to a quality of outcome
not necessarily and if I may say so
reason I want to come in as I think it's
a brilliant question to which we don't
really yet have an answer the reason we
don't have an answer is this we know
that a lot of the differences between
the categories we are talking about are
to do with unequal treatment for example
the pay gap is undoubtedly in part to
due to unequal treatment by employers it
is also due to occupational segregation
and jobs status but the women work for
mission which did fantastic work on this
now what 78 years ago showed that there
is also something like a 25 percent
which is unexplained now one of the
things that we don't know is to what
extent is that because women actually
want different things out of work than
men now I know we're talking about
averages please don't you know that
there are some women who want this in it
but what a court if we think about
categories actually the truth is that
this comes to a very central point which
we wrestled with a lot at the Equality
Human Rights Commission if you believe
in diversity you also have to accept but
groups of people on average might want
different things out of life and they
might bring different things to the
table I mean
a sense that is for particularly on
gender that is one of the the reasons
that I campaign and I beat the guys
people who work for me to put forward
women candidates because I believe that
women will bring something different to
the boardroom
you know I married somebody who had been
running a company for the company for 20
years it owned by her and another woman
every time they bring in a male partner
the whole thing tanks actually they are
smart women and whatever it is they do
and how they do it I think has something
to do with whatever it is that women
bring it that are so the answer to your
question is let's not assume either that
one will automatically follow from the
other and also let's not assume that
that is necessarily a great thing if we
believe in diversity then we also
believe in difference okay thank you
very much we're just about out of time
I'm very sorry we're not allowed to have
any more questions
we're going to have brief summing up
statements from the panel in reverse
order no more than two minutes please
so David as the final speaker you will
go first in the summing up and then we
will have the results of who has been
convinced by the thrilling arguments
made from the stage David give us two
minutes well I ask the audience to
really think what is tearing society
apart and it really in the end is
inequality it may be the fifth
Industrial Revolution artificial
intelligence and the loss of jobs for
much of many people in the developed
world but it's not identity politics
identity politics is a response to those
who for much of human history have been
subjugated and under others and actually
for me this debate is about what is our
common humanity
so yes you do not want a politics that
is solely about identity politics I am
far more interested in what we share and
our civic nationalism that allows us all
to be patriotic allows us all
take a place in British society than I
am solely in a narrow singular ethnic or
gender-based identity that can shuts
down discussion but I absolutely believe
if we have a common destiny then we have
to recognize that there are immense
issues that are structural and that that
structure tends to privilege certain
groups of people over others and we are
rightly at the beginning of the 21st
century challenging those who have held
on to power and been reluctant to give
it up so that we can all share in what
countries like ours have to offer David
thank you very much Trevor two minutes
to sum up four quick points the issue of
a freedom of expression I'm chair of the
index on Censorship came up I asked on
television about two weeks ago in the
discussion about something we sure need
to go into whether it would be
legitimate and I think it's ought to be
to ask this question we know that here
and in North American pretty much
everywhere children of Chinese heritage
outperform pretty much every other
category we know that their performance
is almost unimpacted by their parents
level of education or their family and
household income should we be able to
study why that is happening can we learn
something from that which might help for
example the long tail of
underachievement of the community from
which I icon I think we should and it
might turn out we don't learn anything
it might turn out I I don't believe in
the biological thing at all but if we
cannot ask that question then actually
what we may be doing is depriving some
people of a possibility of change for my
pains and asking this question
I was described in public on Twitter and
elsewhere as a racist by somebody who is
a member of one of our very
distinguished universities now you know
I'm not a sewer I'm not gonna sue this
person but if we cannot actually have
that conversation how can we gain
progress and this is a point I think
that night that Lionel was dealing with
earlier on it's not just the sort of big
stories what we now start to do do we
now say I'm not gonna ask that question
because I know it's going to be trouble
so that's the first point second point I
want to make is yes that is very quick
on these other two points on the issue
of populism and all of that let me say
this gently
I just don't really feel happy about
being told that because I want to raise
some questions I'm blaming women and
black people that it's not what I do the
person over there who raised the
question about populism here's the list
Oh durn salvini Putin lepen balsan ro
Orban Trump these people are coming we
have to think of smarter ways to get in
their way instead of just shouting at
them um and lastly this is a very I'm
gonna make a complicate point so forgive
me if it's not intelligible one of the
things that we already know is that the
changes that are being wrought by
technology are going to affect different
groups of people differently they will
affect women differently in the United
States but the arrival of the driverless
car will be a problem for white men and
not very many other people because that
who the drivers are within a year they
will not just see themselves as people
have been knocked off the road by
driverless cars they will see themselves
as white men who are oppressed we need
to be thinking about how we respond to
these things that's why this debate is
about lot more than as you say those
right a lot more than what happens on
universities or who gets discriminated
against it is about the big changes that
I take
place in our society and if I may just
want to say last one thing I was a bit
disappointed a bit disappointed with
this discussion because somebody said to
me oh I've been to one of those it's
like jeremy carr for the Waitrose
classes and none of you has done that
tonight so Hannah you could put that on
your website Jeremy Kyle for the
Waitrose classes dawn sum up your
arguments in two minutes although Trevor
took three and a half that's fine I was
interested to hear from Trevor that he
was the most left-wing person on the
panel you know more than mere David so
he must be a communist brilliant and
you're not the most left-wing person on
the panel dawn may be suggesting ok
we'll fight on yes I agree with
everything David said and some of the
points are the people raised I think
that identity politics is a small factor
in millennial life and it's a and it
isn't attempt to address in justices in
this or in society it's it's an attempt
to address inequalities that make life
more difficult
it's and it is an attempt to kind of
look at our own behavior and make sure
that we behave well and you know treat
people how they deserve to be treated
and I think the big thing that is serán
unquote society apart it's not identity
politics but it is inequality because if
you are poor it really fills your mind
like it's very difficult to process
other things and if you are extremely
rich your concern is about money again
how to keep that money how to how to
save it and I read a great things
recently about the fact that a lot of
extremely rich people are terrified that
there will be some kind of revolution
and have been buying her bolt holes in
in New Zealand with big bunkers in case
people rise up and try and kill the
super-rich so I think the big thing that
is terror in society apart is inequality
and I think that identity politics is a
small movement that people use to try
and address that in equality
and there isn't a kind of fearful thing
you know that is used to attack people
silenced people and you know hunt down
white men in many ways thank you very
much
dawn Lionel the last two minutes are
yours
I started this event off by trying to
define it identity politics partly
because of when it ended up happening
anyway which is that we sort of slid all
around the place talking about populism
and I suppose it was inevitable that
we'd end up talking about Briggs it I
think it's important to define what
we're discussing and what I what I'm
talking about is a is it's a way of
thinking it's a way of thinking about
ourselves and others and it's a it's a
way of thinking that puts on you and I
label that that you cannot defeat you
cannot think outside of it you can't
defy it it so if you're white you can't
you know you have no right to an opinion
on a whole range of it issues it's it's
a culture and and it's an atmosphere
that's starting to permeate our our
whole society across the West a kind of
super sensitivity and and antagonism
which I find makes my life worse and it
I think it makes all of us less open to
each other but if I had realized that
even though I found David's speech quite
rousing that what we were really
debating was racism and sexism are bad I
think I'd have turned the invitation
down
thank you very much Lionel Trevor thorn
and David I am now Speaker Berko for the
next 30 seconds the result the final
result from magnificent audience here
thank you so much for coming for the
motion let's remember it was 50% before
we heard the August panelists after it
was 50% for the motion after the debate
55% so it's gone up slightly but hold on
David hold on
all we'll have prizes let's not forget
that against the motion before you heard
the August opinions of these panelists
13% that has shot up to 35% with only
10% now undecided so everybody's one and
it shows just how hard public votes are
to interpret and on that note I wanna
say thank you very much to you thank you
very much to intelligence where Hanna
and the team advising such a great
debate and thank you very much to the
panelists
[Applause]